the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like it's a good day
for us house of the dragon fans
according to some new information hbo is
hoping to begin filming on house of the
dragon's second season later this year
[Applause]
now if you've seen my recent videos you
would know there have been rumors that
hbo has already given the green light
for the second season of house of the
dragon i went over this information when
it first hit the internet only a few
weeks ago as a matter of fact an
executive at hbo more or less confirmed
this several months ago during one of
his interviews now during that interview
he said they usually like to see how
well a show does in the ratings before
they think about moving on to the next
season but the way they've been
developing house of the dragon has been
very different from most of their other
shows if you remember house of the
dragons first season was given the green
light before they even seen the first
episode for those of you that don't know
that almost never happens
this is honestly a very big gamble but
they must be confident in the show
otherwise they wouldn't have done that
well now we're starting to already find
out hbo will most likely be filming
house of the dragon's second season
shortly after the first one is over
once again this information is brought
to us by rodanian intelligence a website
who has been very accurate before
their new article says the first season
of the highly anticipated game of
thrones successor show is coming to the
small screen in late august but as we've
said before work has already begun on
house of the dragon's second season back
in may we heard that writing had begun
for the second season of house of the
dragon indicating that hbo had already
given the show a green light to move
forward
now we're hearing that filming for house
of the dragon second season is scheduled
to begin later this year we weren't
given an exact month but as much as we
heard hbo was aiming for the fall or
winter so if this is indeed accurate hbo
will start filming house of the dragon's
second season right around when the
first season will be ending now you do
have to remember that these dates are
not set in stone you never know what
might happen that could force them to do
things differently with that being said
this is still great news
now that we're finally about to be back
in george rr martin's a song of ice and
fire universe with house of the dragon
we are already hearing that they are
working on a second season like i did
for game of thrones in house of the
dragon's first season i will be here
making videos about everything that
happens every step of the way i will be
making videos about every new house of
the dragon episode as well as everything
that happens whenever they start filming
the next season
hopefully i will see all of you back
here for those videos as well i don't
know about all of you but i am getting
very excited for house of the dragon's
first season i cannot wait to finally
see some new episodes that feature
george rr martin's amazing castles and
characters once again we're only about
75 days away from seeing house of the
dragon's first episode and by the looks
of all the new footage and photos it
should be incredible i hope that all of
you will subscribe and join me for the
ride as always i want to thank all of
you for stopping by and watching this
short update video i will make sure to
let you know when and if any new
information is released regarding game
of thrones house of the dragon or the
winds of winter for now have a great day
everyone i will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you